Simplify 3a times a to
the fifth times a squared.
So the exponent
property we can use here
is if we have the same
base, in this case, it's a.
If we have it raised
to the x power,
we're multiplying it
by a to the y power,
then this is just going to
be equal to a to the x plus y
power.
And we'll think about why
that works in a second.
So let's just apply it here.
Let's start with the a to
the fifth times a squared.
So if we just apply
this property over here,
this will result in a to
the fifth plus two-th power.
So that's what those guys
reduce to, or simplify to.
And of course, we still
have the 3a out front.
Now what I want to do is
take a little bit of an aside
and realize why this worked.
Let's think about what a to the
fifth times a squared means.
A to the fifth
literally means a times
a times a times a times a.
Now, a squared literally
means a times a.
And we're multiplying
the two times each other.
So we're multiplying these
five a's times these two a's.
And what have we just done?
We're multiplying a
times itself five times,
and then another two times.
We are multiplying
a times itself.
So let me make it clear.
This over here is
a to the fifth.
This over here is a squared.
When you multiply
the two, you're
multiplying a by itself
itself seven times.
5 plus 2.
So this is a to the seventh
power. a to the 5 plus 2 power.
So this simplifies to 3a
times a to the seventh power.
Now you might say, how do I
apply the property over here?
What is the exponent on the a?
And remember, if I just
have an a over here,
this is equivalent to
a to the first power.
So I can rewrite 3a is 3
times a to the first power.
And now it maybe makes
it a little bit clearer.
A to the first power-- and
the association property
of multiplication, I can
do the multiplication
of the a's before I
worry about the 3's.
So I can multiply
these two guys first.
So a to the first times
a to the seventh-- I
just have to add the exponents
because I have the same base
and I'm taking the
product-- that's
going to be a to
the eighth power.
And I still have
this 3 out front.
So 3a times a to
the fifth times a
squared simplifies to
3a to the eighth power.